oh I probably should have made this
video a couple of days ago but I just
haven't really got around to it
I've been really really really busy with
live stuff recently I hit 25,000
subscribers which still hasn't managed
to sink in just yet
whenever I see subscriber videos on
YouTube they're usually for people who
have just hit a hundred subscribers or
500 subscribers I've never seen that you
wanted to make a video when they've hit
25 thousand it's it's yeah I'm a little
bit scared however I have an idea I have
managed to come up with an idea for a
subscriber video which does not involve
writing all your names down as cool as
those videos are when your name pops up
on screen the rest of it is usually kind
of boring and it might be a little bit
tricky writing down 25,000 peoples
usernames so here's my proposal this is
the thing this is what we're gonna do
this is the plan it's called challenge
charlie it's not extremely original I
understand that already I am going to do
25 user submitted challenges 25,000
names to write down is pretty impossible
25,000 challenges is just insanely
impossible it's it's even more
impossible if that's possible so I'm
gonna do 25 challenges which is probably
quite a lot of challenges because this
is a thank-you video for my subscribers
basically what I'm gonna say is if you
are a subscriber you are allowed to
submit a challenge and if you are not a
subscriber you are not allowed to do to
be a pilot you know I mean I want to
make this as fair as possible so I'm
going to say no video responses
video responses are usually favored in
these kind of circumstances and I know
there are people who don't have webcams
who don't know how to make videos so I'm
just gonna say comments only okay on
this one just comments anyway I want to
have as many individual challenges as
possible so if you are going to submit
one then have a look through the
comments before you do it so make sure
that your challenge hasn't been
suggested already and another idea which
is not mine which I'm going to steal
you've probably already seen the
thumbs-up thumbs-down things on the
comments no one really uses them
properly but today we are going to use
them properly basically what I'm
suggesting is if
you see a challenge that you like give
it a thumbs up and if you see a
challenge that you don't like give it a
thumbs down that way I can look through
and see which one's the most popular
challenges are and choose accordingly I
have been on YouTube for a while and I
know you guys I know you YouTube
calendars and I know that you will
submit challenges which I will not be
able to do I know you'll ask me to eat a
skyscraper I know that you will ask me
to lick Tony Blair's bum and I know that
people going through the comments will
thumbs up the most ridiculous challenges
possible so that's it challenge charlie